Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and yesterday
during my Walking Dead episode 13 video I
asked you all to submit questions about the
many WTF moments.
I picked 10 of them with one bonus question.
Largely it seemed like the biggest questions
everyone had were Beth getting kidnapped,
Daryl’s new friends and Terminus.
Before we get started congratulations to “melovetorun”
for being the week 5 winner of the giveaway.
I’ll be messaging you on your channel for
details.
If you’re finding me for the first time,
just as a way to say thank you to everyone
for being so awesome I’m randomly selecting
a subscriber from the comments on my Walking
Dead reviews to give a $20 amazon giftcard
to.
The next round will start with episode 14
on Sunday.
So let’s answer some questions, there were
a lot of really good ones this week.
Question 1 - Andrew Jones asks do you think
that Glenn is following Maggie's trail?
Or traveling from a different direction altogether
to Terminus?
Yes, so it’s totally possible that those
Terminus maps are all over the place, it’s
hard to guess where Glenn was the last time
we saw him, but in my head I think everyone
either went east or west using the railroad
tracks and Abraham was headed north east.
It’s hard to guess which way Maggie went
when they left the prison but I think the
show wants us to think he’s coming from
behind her.
So that’s what I’m going to choose to
believe.
Circumstances seem like they’re slowing
causing all of the groups to converge at the
Terminus by the end of the season.
Question 2 - Alan Michael asks Who do you
think is in Terminus?
Just because the word Sanctuary appears almost
every time they’re talking about it I’m
choosing to believe it’s the Sanctuary from
the comic books.
Which means if they’re doing a direct adaptation
it would be Negan and The Saviors.
But none of the writers or cast has mentioned
him, so it’s possible that they’re messing
with the story just a little bit.
There’s also the introduction of Daryl’s
new buddies and the Gareth character that
was announced last year.
We still haven’t met him.
So assuming the show sticks to it’s comic
book guns, let’s just say Saviors or the
closest possible thing if they decide not
to use that name.
Either way it’s bad, very bad.
Question 3 - Carolina Aimee asks What did
you think those Daryl/Beth moments throughout
the whole episode meant?
Do you think he will be the one that rescues/finds
her?﻿
That awkward pause that Daryl and Beth had
was because she was trying to get him to admit
that he’d started to believe good things
were still possible.
And what he didn’t say or said with a shrug
was that it was because Beth had started to
rub off on him.
The awkward pause itself did kind of make
it seem like there was some implied sexual
attraction, but I don’t think Daryl sees
it that way.
I think he just cares about her a lot.
More than he’s willing to say out loud.
Question 4 - TheMouseNetwork asks is Gareth
the person that took Beth in the car?
Or Someone else?
So one of the biggest theories about Beth’s
mystery kidnapper is that it’s one person
and it’s the new Gareth character.
Who is a version of the Reverend Gabriel character
from the comic books.
In that story he was accused of being involved
with the kidnapping of Dale.
Which turned out to be The Hunters.
There is a rumor that Gareth is tied to the
Terminus, so I’d say the he was either the
one who abducted her or he was orchestrating
it.
Question 5 - Matthew I asks Do you think anyone
will make it to Terminus before the season
finale or do you think everyone makes it to
terminus in season finale?
l definitely think most of the cast will make
it to Terminus, there has been so much foreshadowing
in the last couple of episodes it would be
a huge audience burn on us if we never actually
got to see it.
They didn’t make it explicit in the episode,
but I also think that Joes’ group, the one’s
Daryl ran into are tied to Terminus too.
Question 6 - MrPixel64 asks Do you think those
guys will help Daryl to find the car/Beth?﻿
They seem pretty terrible so I’ll say no,
but based on everyone slowly being herded
toward the Terminus I think he’ll find her
coincidentally.
Alone with everyone else.
I’m really interested to see how each group
is introduced to the community that already
lives there.
If it’s going to be like their introduction
to Woodbury.
I have a feeling that because Joe’s group
views Daryl as a kindred spirit, they’ll
vouch for him.
They still give off this murdery vibe.
So I don’t think he’s any safer than everyone
else.
Question 7 - Liv Taylor asks How in the world
did Daryl let those guys just sneak up on
him like that?﻿
I think he had just hit a new bottom.
Like spending all that time with Beth had
made him really happy and hopeful again and
then losing her and being on his own and lost
made him die a little inside.
Or die a little more.
He really just gave up for a little while
and given that they ran into him I think geographically,
all of the groups are a lot closer than we
think.
Because Joe was just at that house where Rick,
Michonne and Carl were.
Question 8 - Phimackphil asks do you Think
the Gareth character is going to be a cliffhanger?
I assume you’re talking about either the
next episode or the season finale.
I think we’ll meet him before the finale.
There are really only 3 more episodes left,
so I don’t think the show will go on any
crazy tangents with the exception of whatever
the cliffhanger is for next season.
The teaser for the next episode makes it seem
like it will mostly revolve around Carol and
Tyreese’s group.
We haven’t seen Rick’s group in a couple
episodes and given that we’ve seen Beth
and Daryl for the last two weeks, I don’t
think we’ll meet Gareth until episode 15.
The show has been doing this weird thing where
it focuses on the same characters for a couple
episodes, then jumps to other groups for a
couple episodes, so I expect that trend to
continue in the next episode.
Jumping to characters we didn’t see this
week.
Question 9 - Demik Holdat (no avatar) asks
Do you think that Daryl laying down on the
funeral bed was a sign?
I hope not, Daryl isn’t in the comic books,
so you can’t really say he’s living on
borrowed time.
There are a couple characters that are dead
in the comic books, but still alive on the
show.
I’d put them higher up on the list of potential
deaths.
There’s always the potential that someone
could die trying to save Beth.
But that doesn’t necessarily mean it will
be Daryl.
I haven’t seen any quotes from Norman Reedus,
but I do wonder if he ad libbed jumping in
the coffin or if the writers wrote it in the
script.
Question 10 - Amy Haines asks If Bob had really
been bit do you not think he would have shown
at least some signs or even shown panic whenever
Sasha or Maggie were not around?
He did say that the Walker grazed his bandage,
so either he’s telling the truth and walker
teeth did not touch his flesh or he’s ignoring
that warning sign that Sasha talked about.
One of the things I really liked about the
episode was how ambiguous it was with the
character’s lives.
Everyone almost died at some point.
The writers are doing a really good job of
teasing a big death.
Which I still believe is coming.
Most likely in the finale.
Bonus Question - Marion Swanson asks Do you
think the show actually made a mistake by
displaying Abraham's group so faithfully?
So this is actually a carry-over question
from two episodes ago, but I saw a lot of
other people commenting on the appearance
of Abraham and Rosita specifically.
Mostly that Abraham was a little too out of
shape and Rosita was a little too much of
a Barbie Doll.
I didn’t really mind Abraham’s appearance,
but I did think Rosita seemed a little out
of place with the booty shorts.
I guess in the apocalypse you just have to
do whatever you can to feel comfortable.
I think it would be a bigger issue if she
had more time on screen.
I don’t begrudge little things like that
unless a show forces me to stare at something
all the time.
So thank you guys so much for submitting questions.
This was a lot of fun as always.
Two big things we can look forward to in the
next couple of episodes are meeting Gareth
and seeing the Terminus.
Next week it looks like Lizzie and Mika’s
are in for major trouble.
Be sure to subscribe to get my video.
I’ll post it right after the episode airs.
I’m also posting a breakdown of the Game
of Thrones trailer later tonight.
Right now click here for my top 5 WTF moments
from the episode and click here for that breakdown
video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys in a little
bit.
High Fives!